In Spain we feel very,
very, very,
very proud of our public health system.
In Madrid
7,291 people died without medical assistance
between March and April,
of 2,020.
There was 1 protocol approved by the Community of Madrid
with Isabel Díaz Ayuso at the head,
that prevented the relocation of the elderly
to hospitals.
The Madrid Prosecutor's Office
did not investigate the deaths in the residences.
Political commissions of inquiry
that were constituted in the assembly of Madrid
were closed after the victory on the right.
Ayuso has not received any of the 3 associations
of victims in Madrid.
It is a policy of silence in the face of 1 tragedy
and in a democratic society it is un.
It is unbearable
political leaders
to let people die
and that this has no consequences